احنا بنطالب انه المستشفى هذا يضله شغال
فيش هو المستشفى الوحيد اللي في الشمال
كله شغال ودائما كل شويه الكهرباء بتقطع
وانا حياه ابني بخطر يعني حد يحن علينا وي
يحل ه الوضع على خير تعبنا والله زقنا يا
عمي والله العظيم عشنا حياه ما حد عايشها
الصعب والخوف اللي احنا فيه ما حدش فيه
حنوا علينا ابني انا من البرمو هذا
الفوسفور والفيروسات تسبب معه نتج واسهال
وصار معاه زي انسداد مصارين وعملوا له
عمليه لحتى الان يعني بين الحياه والموت
واحن بدنا يعني لو انه شويه امل من حدا
يحن علينا بدنا حدا يحن علينا يا جماعه كل
شويه بيطفوا الاجهزه وبتكفي الطاقه
الشمسيه على لهم يعني انت عارف كيف هالوضع
في في هالمنطقه بكفي تعبنا والله تعبنا
ايش اسوي ايش بدي احكي للمجتمع الدوله حد
يشوفنا حد يطلع علينا على اطفالنا دخيلكم
شوفوا ايش صار فينا الاطفال بتموت يعني
الموت صر اقرب من الكلام ع الشفه ايش بدي
احكي